[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so Gouge, you go back to the bar and get an ale from there and then walk outside into an alleyway and sit there drinking your ale in the shadows.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll your stealth.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, cool Terry.
[SPEAKER_02]: You want high.
[SPEAKER_02]: One plus ten is eleven.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you're sitting there, and you probably sit there and drink for maybe two minutes.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then you see Folsom rushing down from the market where you had gone first, basically into Red Shore.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he's got this worried look on his face.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you see him coming towards the bar like,
[SPEAKER_01]: Kind of looking in there, trying to see what's going on, and he sees the dead bodies.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: What are you going to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to whistle at them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You hear a whistle, and you see like a figure sitting in the alleyway, if you could call it an alleyway, next to this ramshackle bar.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do I not know who it is?
[SPEAKER_01]: World perception?
[SPEAKER_01]: Seventeen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Plus three.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know.
[SPEAKER_01]: The shape of Gouge.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tall.
[SPEAKER_01]: The way he's lounging.
[SPEAKER_01]: The whistle.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're pretty relieved.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Actually, what do you do?
[SPEAKER_00]: I immediately cast Message.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Since we're far away still.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I message to him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Are you guys alright?
[SPEAKER_02]: I can't speak back through messaging.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, you can.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's just our minds talking.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_02]: A good fight got beat down a bit, but came out on top.
[SPEAKER_02]: Everyone's alive?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: They're back at the ship.
[SPEAKER_00]: Uh... Owen sent them.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Where's Owen?
[SPEAKER_00]: He took me to a ship beyond the merchants.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he's far away, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm walking towards him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I just want to get the information immediately.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm walking towards him.
[SPEAKER_00]: How did you get out of there?
[SPEAKER_00]: Long story short, I blinded him.
[SPEAKER_00]: He had a Toli, a Toli friend who I stabbed.
[SPEAKER_00]: They hurt pretty well and I ran off their ship.
[SPEAKER_00]: You unharmed?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm great.
[SPEAKER_00]: I did not scratch on me.
[SPEAKER_00]: They tried to imprison me and take me to...
[SPEAKER_00]: They tried to take me to King Toli.
[SPEAKER_00]: Take him as his prisoner.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: What now?
[SPEAKER_02]: We takin' the ship and leavin'?
[SPEAKER_00]: Where would we go?
[SPEAKER_00]: Back to Monmurg?
[SPEAKER_00]: Back to Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: I guess so.
[SPEAKER_00]: I ask Gouge.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're at the ship?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, they're near it, by it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is there a huge crowd of people around me?
[SPEAKER_01]: There are people all over the place, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: I get up and start walking to the ship.
[SPEAKER_01]: I say, wait.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then, this is out of question, like, uh, Owen has, does he have a bad reputation here?
[SPEAKER_00]: You have no idea.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have no idea?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Obviously he has allies.
[SPEAKER_01]: Contacts.
[SPEAKER_00]: I was gonna say...
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe if you back me up, I can yell to these people to beware of Owen, to look out for him so he just ruins his reputation here.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'd rather not stir up any type of ruckus, other than what we did.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know, we should get back to the other guys and figure this out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because if he sent that, I don't know if maybe he sent more.
[SPEAKER_02]: Or they let two guys go, which I wasn't happy with, and there might be more coming, so let's get back to that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So the two of you walk back down the docks towards the boat.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're not going to run.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nothing like... You just acted normal.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: I tell him my epic heroicism.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I don't know it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: He brought me into the ship.
[SPEAKER_00]: He tried to spare me from me getting buddy-buddy with him.
[SPEAKER_00]: And tried to kill you three.
[SPEAKER_00]: And they wanted me to, as a prisoner, as an entertainer for, for, for, uh, what's his name, my goodness, Caintoli.
[SPEAKER_00]: And, uh, they gave me a bottle of rum.
[SPEAKER_00]: A shot of it to take before I put my hands in the binds.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I took the glass.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's a heroic Owen Black splashed in his eye, blinding him.
[SPEAKER_00]: I got my rapier out and stabbed his lowly friend and ran out of the ship.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, his friend is very injured, stabbed through his shoulder, plus my sick burn of telling him I hope that stung more than the shot of Rumwood seemed to get him, so he's pretty
[SPEAKER_00]: Pretty weak and...
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Um...
[SPEAKER_00]: I wanted to... Well...
[SPEAKER_00]: I wanted to get Owen as a hostage, but I just... Yeah, I don't know if we can go back.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know if we can go back and try to get him.
[SPEAKER_02]: We need the others for sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm um...
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, because we've all taken a decent amount of damage, so I don't think we should try anything without everyone together.
[SPEAKER_02]: So let's put their two heads together and find out, because I don't know what this place is, if they're gonna...
[SPEAKER_02]: The phone's under protection now, or if nobody gives a shit and we can go get them.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So the two of you walk back to the boat?
[SPEAKER_02]: Mm-hmm.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: You get there and reach your friends.